I don't think it's going to taste weird
but I don't know how I'm gonna get the
thought of like a thousand crickets
screening out of my mind
we're gonna run out of regular protein
yes like one day we're gonna run why not
breathe I'm not a religious man but I'm
praying it tastes like chocolate
do they like let them bleed out before
they bawl where do they blend them like
me with everything intact and then here
it comes
what's up we're gonna show me a cricket
while I eat princess are you oh boy what
you are oh why no no no no no dare wait
eat that for like five bucks yeah we're
heading box it look at them
you're like don't eat my friends oh my
god don't give them voices just just
tastes like chocolate just tastes like
chocolate tastes good
what there's Oreo in there but I just
bit something that had a little like a
little pop to it do you feel like this
is it all affecting your enjoyment of
this it did for a second but now I'm
just gonna have some if you had just
brought me an Oreo shake and said this
is just an Oreo shake I say thank you
but now that we're looking we're doing
this we have the knowledge of the right
there why would you do that ignorant
bliss in the situation I'm so sorry I
ate your brother I don't care good I
know it it is super popular in other
countries I'm just glad that they
shredded it pretty well right I got
another head oh when we want to start to
run out of water and stuff and like we
start to enter some Mad Max it'll get
into the crickets I think like bugs will
be the super protein when we're just
dead here you know I can be charged
gosh damn you went there